welcome back to New rockstars I'm
Whitney van laningham and with the
recent changes to the new Captain
America film's Title and release date
and the release Set photo of Harrison
Ford and Anthony Mackey we've got a lot
to talk about today I'm catching you up
on everything you need to know about
Captain America Brave New World and
speculating on what Harrison Ford's role
as the Red Hulk means for the MCU as
soon as this picture of Ford is Thaddeus
Thunderbolt Ross and Mackie as Captain
America dropped eagle-eyed fans noticed
that Ford's pants are looking a little
torn up at the knee one thing at Ross's
gamma radiated form Red Hulk as all
classic Hulk fans know shredded shorts
like Fords have been the Hulk's
signature garment on the pages of the
comic since his character's debut in The
Incredible Hulk issue number one in 1962
and have followed him through the
majority of his subsequent animated and
live-action roles when comicbook.com's
Brandon Davis interviewed Harrison Ford
recently about Indiana Jones and the
dial of Destiny Ford gave an incredibly
cryptic response as to whether or not
we'd see Red Hulk in Brave New World he
just goes what is the Red Hulk classical
old guy answer he later remarked that
the red Hulk's first live-action
appearance may or may not be included in
the movie which makes me think he was
just plain dumb about his character's
transformation to throw us off his Trail
so what is Red Hulk as Harrison so
eloquently asked Hulk Vol 2 issue number
23 is the best place to start reading up
about Ross's transformation into the Red
Hulk Ross narrates a recap of several
different comics from the 1960s so you
can get The Abridged version of his
character history in this issue highly
recommend reading it before the new cap
drops long story short comic book wraths
has always viewed Hulk as a weapon of
mass destruction and vowed to take him
down at all costs he attempts to level
the playing field by acquiring
superhuman abilities like the hulks
which leads to his death in the
aftermath the leader reanimates him and
when his daughter Betty is killed the
leader seizes the opportunity to exploit
Ross's vulnerability he'll ensure that
Ross is put in charge of running the
country and will bring Betty back to
life but Daddy fatty has to help him
take out the Hulk modak the leader in
Doc Samson siphon energy from the Hulk's
body and channel them in to Ross turning
him into the Red Hulk Red Hulk has
basically the same powers and abilities
as the regular green Hulk with the added
advantage of being able to transform
back and forth between his two forms at
will he's also a sponge for absorbing
energy and too much of it can overcook
him and his immediate surroundings
Allegiance wise Red Hulk oscillates
between anti-hero and villain he's been
an Avenger a pawn of the leader and most
notably the leader of his own
Thunderbolts team as for Harrison Ford's
Hull the shorts and the quotes aren't my
only indication that we'll see Ross Hulk
out with Tim Blake Nelson reprising his
role as Dr Samuel Stern from 2008's The
Incredible Hulk there's no doubt in my
mind that we'll see these two play out
parts of their comic book storyline on
the Silver Screen the MCU is notorious
for working in bits and pieces or even
entire plot lines from the comics into
their movies and TV series feige
basically uses the comics as a road map
to guide the MCU to new
never-before-seen places but if you
haven't read up on the Hulk in a while
I've got the scoop for you Sam Stern's
origin story is the leader can be found
in Tales to astonish number 60 3 where
he recounts the gamma radiation accident
that transformed him working at a
chemical plant Sam is exposed to
extremely high levels of gamma radiation
when a cylinder explodes he gains
heightened intellectual prowess and
eventually his head balloons out like a
watermelon and his skin turned bright
green he uses his heightened intellect
to become a criminal mastermind and even
has the audacity to ruin Betty and
Bruce's wedding if Tim Blake Nelson
shows up to my wedding and just starts
going nuts I'm gonna Hulk out too and
while I don't think that the MCU is
gonna follow every single detail of
Ross's complicated history with the
leader I do think that several important
plot points will draw inspiration from
the comics with Kevin feidey's
confirmation to Entertainment Weekly
that Harrison Ford will be playing Ross
as the President of the United States my
theory is that we'll see the leader
offer to enhance his ammunition against
Bruce Banner's halt by transforming him
into Red Hulk like he does in the comics
not sure if the leader is gonna try to
reanimate Ross's dead body but after
Multiverse of Madness I'm hankering for
more MCU rotting corpse action Ripley of
Kyler set to return his Betty could see
Ross become the Red Hulk to save his
daughter or even bring her back from the
grave we also know that Ford is going to
reprise his role as rats in 2024 as the
Thunderbolts which will show Val's
little collection of super villains
going on missions for the United States
government and I wouldn't be surprised
if they utilized the leader's influence
over him as president in this movie as
well and considering comic book Ross's
experience leading a version of the
Thunderbolts he might just tag in and
show the team how to get the job done
next we gotta talk about the updates
made to Captain America's release date
and title the film's new release date is
July 26 2024 only a few months after its
original slated date in May of the same
year it's taking the slot of the
Thunderbolts which has now been moved to
December 20th 2024 but the biggest
changes in Captain America 4's title
Marvel decided to mix Captain America
New World Order in exchange for Captain
America Brave New World likely due to
the former phrase's roots and races in
the anti-Semitism however in the past
Marvel has presented us with sneaky
alternate titles to throw us off any
potential plot spoilers that may lie in
the actual title most famously Marvel
originally told us that Captain
America's serpent Society was the name
of the movie we now know as Captain
America Civil War because feige quote
didn't want to blow his wad by
presenting the actual title so early in
his announcement Brave New World alludes
to Aldous huxley's dystopian novel of
the same name from the 1930s this book
tells the story of a future society that
environmentally Engineers its citizens
High Intelligence in order to form a
more perfect world scientific
achievements and reproductive technology
sleep learning psychological
manipulation and classical conditioning
have allowed this world state to control
its people except the protagonist who
seized through the and works
against the system to regain true free
will this literary illusion seems to be
a much more accurate way to hint at the
themes of the movie Not only is there a
brand new Captain America navigating
life in the aftermath of his best buddy
Steve Rogers death we know from recent
MCU installments like wakanda forever
and Falcon in the Winter Soldier the Val
is working with the CIA to build a team
of super-powered individuals to do her
Dirty Work behind the scene means she's
already convinced Johnny mayonnaise that
he deserves revenge for the way the
government treated him and that the
super soldier's serum he took was a good
thing baby girl was definitely planning
to gain control and is clearly
manipulating vulnerable susceptible
Heroes like Walker Angelina to help her
succeed as she said to us agent the
world is changing she just leaves out
the part where she's the one changing it
and that she's definitely trying to
change it for the worse that's all the
news I know for now about Red Hulk Brave
New World and the leader but I want to
know what you guys think in the comments
follow me on Instagram on Twitter
whitneypuppy follow new Rockstar
subscribe to new rockstars for more
analysis of everything you love and
thanks for watching bye
[Music]
thank you